so as you all know I'm voting for Bernie
in the Democratic primary this is not a
partisan story I will be voting for
Bernie this is not an attack on Bernie
I'm going to vote for Bernie in the
Massachusetts Democratic primary I am
NOT attacking or supporting any
candidate with this story but the entire
Bernie Bloomberg heart health story that
has been developing over the last 48
hours is really really bad and here's
the the way it's been going down both
Michael Bloomberg and Bernie Sanders are
close to 80 years old they both have
heart had heart issues Bernie Sanders
had a heart attack last year Michael
Bloomberg had one or two stents placed
about 20-25 years ago they should both
release their full medical records
period this doesn't have anything to do
with who's better on health care or
who's better on stop-and-frisk
or who's more or less racially sensitive
this has nothing to do with that okay
Bernie said he'd release his full
records then he backtracked put out
three doctor's letters and says that's
all that we're going to put out there
are Bernie staffers attacking
Bloomberg's heart health with missed
statements and it's toxic and terrible
so let's start there Bernie's national
press secretary Brianna Joy gray
yesterday on CNN listen to this she
likens the Bernie health records
requests to birtherism which is bonkers
and then incorrectly states that Michael
Bloomberg has had heart attacks I don't
think we will release any more medical
records I have those three letters from
the doctors the senator Sanders were
talking about there's there's nothing in
a mother and the doctor saying that he's
fit he had a heart attack yeah what yeah
heart attack in the fall do you think
the American people deserve to know more
about his health going forward I think
the American people deserve to know
exactly as much as every other candidate
has released in this race currently and
historically and what you're seeing
right now is really reminiscent of some
of the kind of smear kind of skepticism
campaigns that have been run against a
lot of different candidates in the past
I'm questioning where they're from
aspects of their their their lineage etc
etc and it's really telling give
none of the same concern is being
demonstrated for Michael Bloomberg who's
the same age as Bernie Sanders who was
suffered heart attacks in the past and
what we're seeing is a kind of um so she
says Michael Bloomberg has suffered
heart attacks in the past plural and
that's not true Michael Bloomberg has
not had any heart attacks it's just not
true it doesn't mean Bloomberg's the
better candidate
Bloomberg's still imploded at
yesterday's debate not that none of that
changes but Bloomberg had a stent put in
for a blocked artery 20 or 25 years ago
now Bernie's press secretary later
corrected and said she misspoke after
being called out saying quote I misspoke
when I said Bloomberg had a heart attack
rather he underwent the same stent
procedure as Bernie Bernie released
three detailed medical reports in
December just like the other candidates
I am finding this to be pretty crazy
okay
the when Trump says I released the
transcript he didn't he released you
know a piece of it when Brianna joy gray
says Bernie released three medical
reports they are doctors letters which
Democrats previously widely said when
Trump released them they were not
sufficient we've just got to be
consistent guys okay Bernie promised his
full record and then backtracked he
asked it is a very reasonable ask given
Bernie's a age and given Bernie's recent
heart attack it is completely and
totally reasonable look up life
expectancy for white males born in the
United States Bloomberg has had stents
put in demanding the same of Michael
Bloomberg is perfectly reasonable
Peabody judge during the debate
yesterday said he'd be willing to
undergo a physical or whatever this is
not about Pete Buddha jej although we
should have the records from everybody
we just need transparency on this issue
I don't think it's like birtherism I
don't think it's a dirty trick I plan to
vote for Bernie in Massachusetts but he
promised it he's nearly 80 he had a
heart attack and he should release
actual full medical records not just
some doctor's letters Biden has had
brain surgery he's nearly 80 we should
know everything there is to know about
Biden's health situation there is no
question that cynical actors can
weaponize this health thing it's not
ages to be concerned about this in
principle
but we've got to be responsible I guess
I believe Briana Joy gray misspoke
although she's been doing a lot of miss
speaking lately I don't know but this is
starting to get ugly on multiple sides
it is not there's nothing wrong with
believing that Bernie should do what he
promised to do which he now says he's
not going to do he should do it Michael
Bloomberg should put out his records
we should get full disclosure from Joe
Biden and we actually may have close to
that from Joe Biden Joe Biden's put out
quite a bit just put out the records
guys that's all and then vote for
whoever you agree with most on the
issues for me it's Bernie it's very
simple but I still want to see that full
medical record one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month
a $25.00 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy comm slash Pakman